Francis Hougun est
des papiers Facebook,
je m'appelle Francis Haugen mais je suis ici
aujourd'hui parce que je crois que les produits de Facebook
nuisent aux enfants de Stoke Division
et affaiblissent notre démocratie.
pour savoir
comment tu vas je veux dire euh comment tu vas
et comment pourrais-tu décrire
l'année que tu as traversée depuis que tu es
sorti en tant que lanceur d'alerte ça a été un
tourbillon comme je t'ai donné que je pense que
le monde avait faim
accroché sur Facebook
c'est vrai que pendant longtemps, les gens avaient
eu le sentiment que quelque chose n'allait pas,
vous savez que Facebook sortirait et et
euh un peu
mauvais pour tous les militants qui soulevaient des problèmes,
mais c'est vraiment satisfaisant d'apprendre
la vérité et je pense que les gens sont vraiment
reconnaissants à  savez en fait que vous savez que
leurs enfants étaient en danger quelque chose se
passait vous savez qu'il y avait une instabilité à
laquelle Facebook a contribué
comment caractériseriez-vous Facebook '  s
actions depuis lors, vous savez que c'est
intéressant, c'est un peu comme
s'ils écoutent, mais c'est
comme s'ils n'entendaient pas le cœur du
message, alors certains des vous
connaissez l'un de mes principaux problèmes  était autour
du rôle de Facebook dans des endroits moins stables
du monde et ils
investissent dans la sécurité d'autres pays
et ils ont fait des choses, vous savez, ils ont
déployé le programme sans langue Left
Behind qui couvre 200 langues,
mais vous savez qu'il y a comme  quatre ou cinq
mille langues dans le monde et donc
c'est comme s'ils en entendaient parler, mais
en même temps, vous savez qu'ils
ne font rien pour changer leurs
produits, je veux dire pour moins, vous
savez qu'ils ne donnent pas plus aux enfants  des outils pour
s'aider eux-mêmes à échapper à l'algorithme ou
à modérer leur propre utilisation, car
ces choses iraient à l'encontre de leurs
modèles commerciaux et reviendraient à la question de la
langue, pourquoi est-ce un problème si urgent
, comme pourriez-vous nous donner quelques
exemples de la mesure dans laquelle je  Cela peut aller quand vous
ne surveillez pas suffisamment certaines
langues dans certains endroits du monde,
donc euh très très rapidement en 2018,
Facebook est passé d'essayer de vous garder
sur le site aussi longtemps que possible ouais
à vous utiliser dans le système pour
encouragez d'autres personnes afin qu'elles
produisent plus de contenu, donc lorsque vous mettez un
commentaire lorsque vous mettez quelque chose comme quelque chose,
vos amis créent plus de contenu et
ils ont donc commencé à dire que le contenu qui obtient
plus d'interactions est un meilleur contenu, mais
malheureusement, comme Mark Zuckerberg lui-même l'a
dit
engagement-  le classement basé est dangereux
parce que nous sommes attirés par cliquer dessus pour
s'engager avec un contenu plus extrême il a dit
que c'est dans un livre blanc ça date de 2018.
euh vous pouvez dire que dès qu'ils ont
fait le changement ils ont commencé à réaliser
certaines choses
et partis politiques sur  la gauche et
la droite en Europe dans les six mois
qui ont suivi euh ce changement, ils ont commencé à signaler
l'e-mail que vous avez modifié l'algorithme
parce qu'avant, nous pouvions partager
quelque chose  comme un livre blanc sur notre
politique agricole, ce n'est pas la chose la plus
excitante au monde, je suis d'accord, mais
nous avons pu voir d'après les statistiques que les gens l'ont
lu, les gens ont passé du temps avec lui
maintenant si nous publions exactement le même contenu,
c'est des grillons
maintenant si nous le faisons '  ne pas prendre des positions extrêmes des
choses que nous savons que même nos
électeurs n'aiment pas tellement qu'elles
ne sont pas distribuées
c'est une chose dans un endroit comme l'Europe
ou en France ou au Canada où
il y a beaucoup de stabilité, nous
avons beaucoup de  L'histoire du capital social autour de la
démocratie, mais quand cela va dans des
pays où peut-être que Facebook
est essentiellement Internet, vous savez que 80 ou 90 du
contenu dans le monde dans la plupart des langues
n'est que sur Facebook
lorsque vous commencez à donner une
distribution disproportionnée à des idées plus extrêmes qui
peuvent conduire à  la violence bien et pourquoi
pensez-vous qu'il est si difficile pour Facebook ou méta
maintenant de mettre en œuvre ces changements que vous
posez pour une excellente question si nous ne nous
concentrons pas sur le contenu, nous pouvons nous concentrer sur la
conception du produit i  Dans le cas de Facebook, il y a de
petits changements qu'ils peuvent faire, comme
dire avant de partager un lien, vous
devez cliquer dessus
comme si ce n'était pas suffisant pour qu'il apparaisse dans
votre flux et que vous le diffusiez, vous
devez cliquer dessus avant de  re-partagez-
le parce que cela ne traite pas du
contenu, il traite du comportement, cela fonctionne
dans tous les pays du monde ou imaginez que
quelque chose apparaît dans votre fil d'actualité et
qu'il vient de quelqu'un Au-delà des amis d'
amis ouais imaginez si vous disiez hé
Je ne connais pas cette personne,
vous pouvez toujours dire ce que vous voulez, nous devons le
copier et le coller pour le partager,
c'est le même impact que l'ensemble du
programme de suivi des faits tiers, mais cela
fonctionne dans toutes les langues du monde, ce
qui est intéressant, donc la raison  pourquoi
ils ne font pas ces choses, c'est qu'ils
réduisent un peu la quantité de contenu dans le
système et cela
signifie que vous restez sur Facebook un peu
moins longtemps et cela signifie que vous avez cliqué sur
un peu moins de publicités
et donc leur incitation est  à h  avoir
autant de contenu circulant aussi librement et
rapidement que possible dans le système afin que
vous gagniez plus d'argent tout est question de
modèle commercial tout est question de
modèle commercial existe-t-il un modèle que nous
devrions suivre en ce moment dans le monde en
termes de pièces législatives à reproduire
donc une chose qui est enthousiasmante à propos de
la forme que la loi canadienne a
prise, c'est qu'elle a emprunté beaucoup de
modèles vraiment réussis de la
loi sur les services numériques, qui est la loi que l'
Europe a adoptée euh plus tôt cette année,
donc la loi sur les services numériques se concentre sur
la transparence, vous savez, nous avons le droit
de savoir ce qui se passe sur ces
plateformes, nous avons le droit de savoir ce
que nous mettons dans notre esprit et cela
se concentre sur euh les entreprises devant s'engager
dans un processus de discussion des risques juste un
mois avant euh le premier  des articles sont
sortis couvrant mes révélations, le Sénat a
donné un délai à Facebook en disant hé,
mettons-nous à niveau, nous savons que
quelque chose se passe avec les enfants, vous devez
nous dire pourquoi  à vous savez et au lieu de
partager toute recherche Facebook est revenu
et a dit leur a écrit une lettre de six pages
disant que nous n'allons rien vous donner
et parce que nous n'avions pas de lois en place
aux États-Unis qui obligeaient
Facebook à partager  informations sur les risques, la
conversation s'est terminée là jusqu'à ce que mes
révélations soient publiées et ce qui s'est passé
avec cela, c'est que nous avons découvert que Facebook
avait beaucoup de recherches sur
des choses en ligne pour les enfants, comme des entretiens avec des
enfants où ils disaient que les enfants
utilisaient systématiquement le récit d'un toxicomane
pour décrire leur utilisation des réseaux sociaux  les médias
ils disent que ça me rend misérable je ne peux pas
arrêter de l'utiliser si je pars je serai
ostracisé comme si c'était assez
sans équivoque nous nous demandons tous ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur de
l'esprit de Mike M. Zuckerberg
euh comment devrions-nous voir la gouvernance du gouvernement
le style de gouvernance qu'ils ont sur
Facebook, je veux dire les niveaux supérieurs de
Facebook, il doit y avoir à côté de vous une
sorte de descente en ce moment,
j'ai une énorme quantité d'emp  athy pour Mark
parce qu'il a passé toute sa
vie d'adulte le PDG de Facebook vous savez qu'il a
commencé quand il avait 19 ans. les gens lui ont dit
pendant 10 ans qu'il était le sauveur de l'
humanité comme littéralement en 2016 en avril
ils organisaient des défilés pour lui en
les rues en Afrique
euh parce qu'il était comme l'homme qui a
amené Internet en Afrique
, puis a avancé six mois plus tard
et les gens disent que Facebook
ruine la démocratie,
il est presque impossible pour une personne de
garder à l'esprit l'idée qu'elle
pourrait être  responsable de centaines de
milliers de morts et donc en ce moment
nous sommes tous pris en otage par
le fait que Mark s'est
entouré de gens qui le rassurent
que tout va bien,
qu'il est en fait le seul responsable dans
la salle  parce qu'il protège la liberté
d'expression alors qu'en réalité les choses
dont je parle ressemblent à cette plus grande
part du gâteau Au-delà de la modération de contenu
qui ne touche pas à la liberté d'expression, mais
il le fait  Je ne veux même pas penser que ses
produits pourraient blesser les gens parce que
c'est tellement difficile que Facebook et Mark soient
la même chose maintenant dans son esprit, nous pourrions
avoir l'impression que les algorithmes sont
intrinsèquement mauvais et nous devons
imaginer quelque chose d'un modèle différent
basé sur quelque chose d'autre, les algorithmes peuvent
apporter de bons aspects à notre
vie en ligne Je pense que la vraie conversation que nous
devons avoir est de savoir quel système d'
incitations quel système de responsabilité
avons-nous besoin de mettre les algorithmes à l'intérieur
euh parce que c'est comme les voitures vous
savez  les constructeurs automobiles
connaissaient depuis des années les ceintures de sécurité ils
connaissaient les colonnes de direction pliables
ils connaissaient les airbags et ils ne les ont pas
mis dans leurs voitures cela semble fou
il s'est écoulé 20 ans entre le moment où nous avons eu la
première voiture avec une ceinture de sécurité et être
légalement mandaté avec des ceintures de sécurité dans
chaque voiture et
c'est l'une de ces choses où ces
entreprises savent comment fabriquer ces
produits de manière plus sûre, mais à moins que nous
faites des incitations comme la transparence forcée,
ils ne seront pas
incités à agir et responsables avec
c'est vrai pour Facebook je pense que c'est
encore plus pour tic tac ouais vous
devinez ce que je suis ma prochaine question je
veux dire avec nous-mêmes nous  J'ai vu l'
année dernière, je veux dire la quantité d'
influence de Tick Tock et leur
algorithme semble être vraiment puissant et
puissant et vous savez à quel point vous êtes tôt à
propos de
Tick Tock ouais alors Tick Tock ne vous fait aucune
promesse d'utilisateur vous savez le  le seul
problème qu'ils vous posent c'est euh on
va vous inspirer pour regarder une autre vidéo
qui va être si bonne que vous allez
vouloir regarder une autre vidéo
euh et ça veut dire qu'euh comme ils peuvent
faire un certain nombre de choses dans les coulisses
ils ne sont peut-être pas évidents et il y
a quelques années,
ils abattaient toutes les
personnes visiblement homosexuelles ou visiblement handicapées pour les
protéger contre l'intimidation,
donc la raison pour laquelle cela me fait si peur
est en ce moment nous  'r  Je ne parle pas
vraiment de l'influence du Kenya sur ces
endroits vulnérables très fragiles du monde,
mais nous avons vu cet été avec les
élections au Kenya la première fois que le
contenu incendiaire sur Tick Tock
provoquait des conflits et je m'attends à
voir toutes les choses que nous  J'ai vu avec
Facebook au Myanmar et en Éthiopie se
révéler bien pire que Tick Tock et
enfin euh, nous avons de nombreux utilisateurs de Facebook qui
écoutent cette interview, quel
serait le seul conseil que vous leur donneriez
pour avoir une
expérience en ligne sécurisée sur Facebook
un, euh,
leur parle du modèle commercial pour
parler du défilement de la salle de sport et de l'
importance de
comprendre de manière réaliste à quel point vous utilisez
ces systèmes, la plupart des téléphones ont maintenant des fonctionnalités de
temps passé comme voir
combien de temps vous passez sur les
réseaux sociaux  demandez-vous comment je veux
passer du temps dans ma vie comme si je voulais
faire trois heures par jour est-ce que je veux faire 30
minutes par jour comme si je n'étais pas un absolutiste
Je ne vais pas dire que vous devez vous débarrasser
de vos réseaux sociaux, mais je veux que
vous viviez consciemment avec les réseaux sociaux.
Je veux que ce soit un outil pour vous, pas pour
vous. Je ne veux pas que vous soyez un outil.  pour
eux
Francis
merci beaucoup
j'espère à bientôt j'espère aussi à
Montréal ouais merci prends soin de toi